[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
il ya des millénaires
[Musique]
nobi nobi
regard
[Musique]
et nouvelle volée
à
[Musique]
steak est un steak et la liga
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
k
et
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu te sens bien
je
c'est pas chez vous mais j'ai kiffé le
sont franchement c'est succès là c'est
son premier album solo vous le
connaissez bien sûr il faisait partie
des one direction
je suis très très très fort vraiment je
si on est très fort alors c'est son
premier album solo et c'est vrai que
voilà vous depuis votre séparation des
one direction
vous avez vendu déjà en soi c'est son
plus haut il a pu fait déjà plusieurs
albums solo mais il a vendu plus de 18
millions de singles en deux ans au lieu
d'annoncer son nouvel album et dans
celui-là j'ai l'impression est ya
beaucoup de sang sont beaucoup de sons
on a écouté very soon chaud et assez
assez hs1 perche renaud hensen jours oui
et l'album est très très très très fort
et en paix avec nous est ce que est ce
que est ce que de travailler en groupe
ça vous manque ou est-ce que vous êtes
bien en solo you as you are good love
you you well as aimé tu peux me traduire
ça te plaît alors il en train de dire
que c'est génial
[Rires]
c'est bien
deux ambiances mais qu'il aime bien être
tout seul aussi c'est cool d'être tout
seul aussi alors c'est quatre ans après
la sortie du dernier album du groupe en
direction d'auch qui revient avec cet
album solo je vous le redis déjà 18
millions de singles en deux ans en solo
l'album est fou c'était un grand bonheur
nous avons arrêté dix élus que j'étais
super content qu'il vienne
alors me faire
[Applaudissements]